[Music]
Martin Luther King was now playing a
leading role in the nonviolent movement
inspired by Mahatma Gandhi he believed
that love was the strongest weapon
available in the struggle for freedom a
movement which requires ideas vision
planning and funding raising money was a
constant that's all we ever seemed to be
doing and I once told dr. King that I
was tired of being a beggar I found a
great indignity that and to go back to
explain to people constantly what our
movement was about once you experience
the movement how could you do anything
but supported on August 28th 1963 the
largest manifestation of the civil
rights movement was held and the march
on Washington for Jobs and Freedom
gathered more than 200,000 people in a
demonstration at the Lincoln Memorial in
Washington DC the march on Washington
demonstrated that there were more than
just black people who are interested in
the liberation movement that there was a
vast number of americans and the march
on washington gave off dr. King the
opportunity to demonstrate the vastness
of our reach it was a very important
event for America one day live in a
nation where they will not be judged by
the color of our skin but by the content
of their character I have a dream today
so winning it's both though you go back
and look at the speech he doesn't really
talk about the Civil Rights Act it
doesn't talk about the pending
legislation instead says that you might
be here to try to achieve this immediate
goal but I'm here to tell you that the
goal is actually something the prize is
much broader and simply a civil rights
bill and that's why he goes back he
talks about the architects of the
Republic that promise of the Declaration
of Independence that all people are
created equal and endowed with certain
inalienable rights that's a human rights
idea that's not a civil rights idea
[Applause]
in July of 1964 the Civil Rights Act was
signed into law which banned
discrimination based on race color
religion sex or national origin
on March 21st 1965 Martin Luther King
along with other leaders and thousands
of nonviolent activists began their
march from Selma to Montgomery in an
effort to demonstrate their desire of
african-american citizens to exercise
their constitutional right to vote the
March had been attempted twice before
both ending in violence and claiming the
lives of two civil rights activists
Martin Luther King had demanded federal
protection for the March and with the
final effort he succeeded by having
president lyndon b johnson declare on
national television their cause is our
cause we shall overcome
in August 1965 President Johnson signed
the Voting Rights Act that prohibits
racial discrimination in voting summer
was the end result of everything that we
had done it was in fact the beginning of
the end but the end that would make the
difference for all of us to know
you